on dirait que notre reporter solène
gaudin bonsoir solène c'est tout un
symbole d'un symbole fort envoyé à
emmanuel macron et oui stéphanie à deux
ans de la prochaine élection
présidentielle le parti des manuels
macro la république en marche passe de
314 à 288 députés
il perd ainsi la majorité absolue à un
siège près et c'est aussi une première
dans l'histoire de la vème république il
n'y a jamais eu autant de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale en tout depuis
aujourd'hui il y en a neuf petites
composent ce groupe écologie démocratie
solidarité
alors il se compose de marcheurs et
d'aix marcheurs ils se disent ni de la
majorité ni de l'opposition ils se
valent et indépendant mais on sait que
depuis plusieurs mois le projet de
fonder un nouveau groupe était
l'intention de plusieurs anciens de la
république en marche notamment matthieu
orphelin ou encore cédric villani je
vous propose de les écouter ce groupe
écologie démocratie solidarité par des
députés qui souhaitent porter au plus
fort qu'ils puissent ces valeurs dans le
redémarrage dans la feuille de route qui
arrive après l'épidémie écologie
démocratie solidarité des enjeux que
nous font vivre dans le dialogue avec
les sciences avec les citoyens alors
pourquoi maintenant parce que vous
n'ignorez pas que on est face à un
problème environnemental majeur que ce
soit lâchement climatique
où que ce soit et questions de
biodiversité par ailleurs vous n'ignorez
pas non plus que la crise va impacter
sur le quotidien de beaucoup de
françaises et de français et
particulièrement sur les questions de
solidarité
on a repensé notre modèle
on a fait un certain nombre de
propositions à travers ce groupe c'est
un groupe politique avec une intention
forte c'est de faire des propositions
pour la france ce sont donc plutôt des
anciens de l'als gauche de la république
en marche leur projet n'est pas encore
clairement défini ils ont annoncé
vouloir oeuvrer pour le monde d'après
suite à l'épidémie de coronavirus mais
pour l'instant c'est un tout petit
groupe à l'assemblée nationale ils ne
sont que 17 députés
et même si mathieu orphelin a assuré que
d'autres députés ont manifesté leur
intention de les rejoindre
on peut se demander quel poids aura ce
groupe à l'assemblée nationale merci
solène gaudin au palais bourbon